like I don't know if so if I tell you I
have pink shoes on yeah how do you find
out what color my shoes are by looking
at it B don't wear pink shoes or by
someone else telling me about it
thethy person TR person so so if we
could look at the evidence Left Behind
of the prophets that wouldn't I wouldn't
need to tell you what to think I could
show you where to look have you looked
at the archology the prophets of the
Bible l m new is on a different m
new the one I know I mean the one I know
about when it comes to archology they
have not discovered uh nothing about
Moses like according to the Bible okay
uh story okay have you looked I did look
about Moses yeah I did M about M that
story would could match in with your
book as
well it match our book yes match cuz we
don't differ that much what I'm saying
historically
aric just archology today so from
archical point of view it doesn't match
with your Bible story why not because
there is not any story of Israelites
leaving uh Egypt which we know not
Egypt even one okay sorry sorry even
though there is a Jewish archology
saying that well forget what who what
they are just no no I'm just telling you
because yeah say because I'm showing you
from their own people okay cuz we as a
Muslims when you read Islamic sources M
and Pharaoh is not the Pharaoh they're
talking about
now I mean Pharaoh king of Egypt it says
but I just want to focus on just the
evidence so later on with Musa it goes
to the Mount cyani and then he splits
The Rock and then and all these things
they all match the journey that they
take so once you find one place you can
walk and then go to the next so they're
all interconnected as a map and we can
go and visit these places so I came
which places Matt SI M SI God came down
burn the top of the mountain and the
golden cast the mountain of Si where is
Mt C you seen if I had my phone I'd show
you it yeah are you sure it's the
mountain cuz the one I have seen is the
mountain that which is in Saudi now yeah
but they moved it because they're
showing like uh what they call it Moses
name and all of that I give you this
knows
best what's your
name be honest there's more there's more
important issues that we should be
discussing more than me me out there's
more important issues we should be
discussing than of course than this
archical evidences you are not start to
identifying that the book is true and
then go from there because I was
understand that but what I'm saying to
you
what I'm saying to you like according to
the Bible that you have okay to know a
true Prophet you know how to know true
Prophet according to the Bible you tell
me according to the Bible if you read
Deuteronomy it says that if a prophet
speaks in my name about the things which
were to happen in the past and doesn't
not come to pass he's a false prophet
okay and if it does come to pass is a
true
Prophet
evidence second let me finish my point I
respect yes so my point here is that I'm
I'm very surprised that you trying to
speak about an Evidence about Propet
stick to evidence I like to you have
sorry brother I hope you're listening
cuz I'm I don't like speak for the sake
of speaking you know I didn't leave my
wife and my children who I love too much
for the sake of coming to my time I'm
coming here to help people to guide them
Allah's permission so my point to go
back to is in the Bible it gives you
criteria that in order F to know true
Prophet if he speaks in the name of God
about things about the future does not
come to pass no true Prophet if he come
to pass he a true are you happy with
this yeah I mean there's a Hadith isn't
there that it say end 100 Years After
I'm just
speaking criteria AG so now if I bring
you what prophet Muhammad said many
things he prophesied and he came to pass
are you going to accept as a true
Prophet no CU I study prophecy I study
end time prophecy so a lot of them look
similar to the Bibles but the bibles are
more accurate
great look
first if I show you Prophet Muhammad
prophesied about the future and he came
to pass according to your Bible is he
the true Prophet so if you understand
how the Bible how the Quran was
collected
I'm I mean stick to the point the point
is look look look you have to be
consistent listen if it's an
amalgamation of texts around at the
Town twoes the Bible see prophecies in
the Quran can I read the Quran I see
lots of sim similarities Quran first I'm
just talking about general principles
general principles cuz I want to see if
you're going to be consistent or not
okay so now according to the Bible if a
prophet prophesies about something and
it comes to pass therefore he a true
Prophet so therefore if any person
according to your Bible prophesies about
things and it come to pass is a true
Prophet not all of them are been
fulfilled in the Bible we're talking
about the
and we have double fulfillment as well
prophecy I show you many prophecies that
Prophet Muhammad said it's been been
fulfilled wasam prophesied in the Bible
that's a different topic I'm talking
about Muhammad
himself prophesizing about the future
like for example Prophet Muhammad said
it will come a time when interest you
know interest yes usually that's
interest will become widespread even if
you are not involved directly will
affect you this impossible to happen at
the time Prophet
Muhammad who existed 1,400 years ago
because that time interest was
widespread and even if you're not
involved comment I don't know about
interest historically speaking now I
couldn't comment that is that a strong
one yeah because why that time there was
no banks now for example Now by law if
you have more than £22,000 in your own
house you have to put in the bank okay
you have to put the money in the bank
when you put your money in the bank even
if you tell them clearly explicitly I
don't want any account that deals with
interest they will say yes but yet they
will still use your money for interest
okay so even if you are not involved
directly still affecting you so the
question I'm going to ask the question
prophecy corre the question ask
ourselves how a man that existed 1, 400
years ago prophesies about whiches there
was any indication it would
OCC it says the testimony of Jesus
Christ is prophecy write these things
before so you know that I am God 355
prophecies from the Old Testament in the
New Testament the end times there is
only most historically documented
through prophecy that's happening
now no
noal don't about buta I don't I don't
think that Esa is Jesus because I don't
see anything documented so when did it
name Jesus Jesus
Yeshua show me wait in every step by
step brother brother let me help you let
me help how you help me digress from the
point so in every every language when we
see the translation of Jesus it says
God's salvation yes but in Arabi in in
Islam he's called Isa that's the only
time where it's not referred to as God's
salvation his name even in the Biblical
Hebrew it's y in the Paleo Hebrew it's
behold the nail behold the hand and and
the number counts 26 Agape God's perfect
love for us and a reciprocal love for
him the language is in three ways so
even in his name it identifies who God
is and what he's going to
do so why why his name change not speak
about
jesuses we not even speaking about Isa
we're speaking about the the criteria of
a prophet Hood which from your own Bible
so I'm showing you if you do accept that
criteria I think the river in thing is
is not as strong as the ones I'm not
talking about R I'm talking about the
prophecy about the reer is so powerful
because before if he invol interest he
can affect me I don't have to put my
money in his account step by step so you
digressing from the points completely
but for the sake of argument can you
show me where jesus' mother called him
Yoshua go Yeshua God salvation show
should call him Yeshua she didn't he is
God's salvation you should call him and
his name should be called him Manel God
With Us yeah yeah
so should he should be Everlasting
father as well has multiple titles no
problem show me where he married M show
me where his mother called him
Everlasting father name Muhammad talk
about mhammad
no
the a point speaking because why you
know what he's doing I'm telling you
about Scotland and he's speaking about
China Scotland not China holding you to
the same lens you hold how I'm not
holding you I'm just talking about I
think the best way for people that
listen is anywh people can be
people are watching they can
seear outside look at the archology
and confirming it God be true and every
man Li I don't have to defend the Bible
I attack it it defends itself how defend
itself the Bible doesn't defend itself L
you I love Jesus too cool no e said I
don't agree that the same person but if
you say you love that's fine no no no no
first like I said to you
listen take
straight
path no no no I
don't because I doer because I do
evidence theer because
I because I do evidencebased things I
try and prove
Muhammad can you
prove yes of course okay do you know
about prove do you know about manuscript
you about Coptic manuscript you know
about Armenian manuscript okay if you go
there's a book was written by an
American
Professor yeah his name something no no
he's getting manuscript back dayet
Muhammad's time speak about Prophet
Muhammad speak so bir dat Prophet
Muhammad's time understand before
the a it's a talking I don't know what
you talking about than go God loves you
have a lovely day take care byebye
become
Muslim tested them side by side of the
evidence was Christian no Jesus was a
Jew
he that's his background Jesus was the
background what was his religion what it
was Jewish there's no Jewish religion
show me the Old Testament that's not
Jewish fulfilled all the prophecy whole
action of the Jews can you show us
Jewish religion in the
Bible this a Christian way they can
answer
anyway people are watching the C clearly
he couldn't answer no question he
basically I told him in the Bible tells
us in order to know a true prophet he
will prophesy and will come to prophecy
I just showed him one one one there's
thousands of prophecies that Prophet
Muhammad said and it's been fulfilled so
I could have just told him but one
prophecy was enough okay so what he did
instead of being consistent with his
criteria when he noticed the criteria
that has been mentioned in the bible
Prophet Muhammad am did fulfill it he
turned against his own criteria and by
the way that's what Allah in the Quran
about the yah when they know Prophet
Muhammad is the true Prophet they start
make they start rejecting even Moses
Subhan Allah even they said who is Moses
anyway Subhan Allah and this the way of
people
of Allah guide him and by the way
there's a book was written by American
propa which gathered and compiled many
manuscripts back that prophet Muhammad's
time and after him 100 years after
speaking about Prophet Muhammad wasallam
and about the companion so outside
Islamic sources